Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
J'aimerais commencer aujourd'hui
par vous raconter une histoire.
Cette histoire, c’est l’histoire de Paul.
Paul est un étudiant de 23 ans,
en école de commerce.
Quelques mois après la rentrée,
arrive la traditionnelle
soirée d’intégration.
Évidemment, Paul n’a pas encore les codes.
Il ne connaît pas le côté
jeans, baskets, bière chaude.
Il va décider de s’habiller
sur son trente-et-un.
Il va mettre son plus beau costume.
Il va sortir la montre que
ses parents lui ont achetée
spécialement pour son admission.
Il va prendre avec lui son nouvel iPhone.
Paul va passer une super soirée.
Il va boire, boire, boire beaucoup.
Danser, chanter
et arrive bientôt 5 h du matin.
L'heure de rentrer chez lui.
Paul va décider de prendre le premier RER.
Vous vous en doutez,
alcool et fatigue mélangés,
Paul va s’endormir dans le RER
et se réveiller au bout de la ligne
dans une ville qu’il ne connaît pas.
Alors, Paul va décider de changer de quai.
Il s'aperçoit très vite
qu'un homme le suit.
Il se retourne.
Le jeune homme a l’air sympa.
Il commence à parler
et lui demande son chemin.
Les questions s’enchaînent.
Finalement, Paul est plutôt rassuré
que quelqu’un fasse le chemin avec lui.
La conversation continue.
Puis, l’homme commence à lui demander
des informations sur son style de vie,
la marque de sa montre,
et d’un coup, la conversation
va prendre un tournant inattendu.
Le jeune homme va lui dire :
« Vas-y, file ta montre et ton iPhone ! »
Paul, abasourdi, ne sait pas quoi faire.
Il ne répond pas.
Le jeune homme insiste :
« Vas-y, je t’ai dit,
file ta montre et ton iPhone. »
Paul regarde autour.
Personne. Personne pour l’aider.
Aucune caméra.
Il a peur.
Il a peur qu’on lui fasse du mal.
Alors, il va décider de céder et
il va lui donner la montre et l’iPhone.
Sur tout le chemin du retour,
Paul va ressentir de la honte
et de la culpabilité.
Pourquoi n’a-t-il pas dit non ?
Pourquoi n’a-t-il pas lutté ?
Il aurait pu courir, appeler quelqu’un.
Et puis, c'est un peu de sa faute.
C'est lui qui a bu.
C’est lui qui s’est endormi dans le RER
et qui s’est réveillé au bout de la ligne.
Il ressasse l’événement
sur le chemin du retour
et il hésite avant d’en parler à ses amis.
Il hésite beaucoup parce qu'il a honte,
honte de ne pas s'être défendu.
Le soir arrive et il décide
d'appeler un de ses amis.
Son ami, c'est Jules.
Il était également présent
à la soirée d’intégration
et Jules va lui dire :
« Non mais mec, dédramatise.
Honnêtement, ça arrive à plein de monde.
Tu vas aller au commissariat, tu vas
porter plainte et ça va être réglé. »
Ni une ni deux,
Paul se rend au commissariat.
Il est accueilli par deux commissaires
qui vont l’interroger
longuement sur l’événement.
Paul est encore abasourdi, étourdi.
Il ne sait pas quoi répondre.
Il n’est pas forcément
cohérent dans ses propos.
Les questions s’enchaînent.
La première va être :
« Attendez, jeune homme, pour
bien comprendre la situation.
Quand il vous a demandé
votre montre et votre iPhone,
vous n’avez pas dit non directement ?
Vous étiez dans un espace public ?
Il ne vous menaçait pas avec un couteau ?
Finalement, pas de raison d’avoir peur. »
Deuxième question :
« Vous étiez habillé comme ça ?
Je veux dire avec ce costume,
montre apparente, iPhone dans la poche ?
Vous vous doutez bien que ça attire l’œil
quand même, faut pas s’étonner après. »
D'autres questions s'enchaînent.
Finalement, la plainte va être
déposée et enregistrée.
Cet événement va certainement entraîner
chez Paul des stress post-traumatiques,
angoisse, anxiété,
peur de prendre le RER seul.
Pourquoi j’ai décidé
de commencer par cette histoire ?
Cette histoire, il s’agit d’un vol.
C’est assez simple à imaginer.
On le sait tous.
C’est un acte pénalement répréhensible
qui peut aller jusqu’à
sept ans d’emprisonnement.
Les propos des proches de Paul et
des commissaires ont été exagérés,
puisque, on le sait, dans le cas d’un vol,
jamais on ne va culpabiliser la victime
ou lui reprocher de ne rien avoir fait.
Maintenant, j’aimerais bien vous
laisser imaginer une autre situation.
Cette situation,
c’est la situation de Lola.
Ce sont deux situations
qui ne sont en rien comparables,
mis à part le fait qu’elles ont lieu
pendant la même soirée d’intégration
et que la typologie des épreuves
subies vont être les mêmes.
Lola, c’est elle
qui m’a raconté l’histoire
et je vais vous la raconter aujourd’hui.
Evidemment, dans cette situation,
les faits ne seront pas exagérés.
Lola, étudiante de 23 ans,
en école de commerce.
Quelques mois après la rentrée,
c’est l’heure de la soirée d’intégration.
Elle s’habille sur son trente-et-un.
Elle passe une excellente soirée.
Elle danse, elle boit,
elle boit énormément.
Puis arrive 5 h du matin.
L'heure de rentrer chez elle.
Elle habite loin.
Elle est alcoolisée.
Elle a peur de traverser la ville seule.
Alors, un de ses amis,
Jules, le même qu’au début,
s’approche et lui propose de la
ramener très gentiment chez elle.
« Tu ne vas pas rentrer comme ça.
Tu as vu ton état ? »
Ils font chemin ensemble,
et arrivés chez Lola,
elle réalise très vite
que Jules a d’autres attentes.
Il va insister.
Elle va lui dire non.
Elle va lui dire qu’elle n’a pas envie.
Qu’elle a vraiment trop bu.
Et puis qu’ils sont amis.
Il insiste. Il insiste vraiment.
Après tout, il a été sympa.
Il l’a ramenée chez elle quand même.
Il insiste tellement que Lola
commence à avoir peur.
Jules va prendre ses hésitations
et sa gêne pour un oui.
Lola a le regard vide.
Elle attend que ça se termine.
La situation de Lola n’est
malheureusement pas un cas isolé.
Une étudiante sur 20 va être
victime de viol pendant ses études.
Un tiers des jeunes entre 18 et 24 ans
considèrent que lorsqu’une femme dit non,
elle veut en fait dire oui.
Revenons à Lola.
Elle va certainement
y repenser toute la nuit,
ressentir honte et culpabilité.
Pourquoi n’a-t-elle pas agi ?
Elle aurait pu se lever, courir,
sortir de son appartement.
Et finalement, c’est un peu de sa faute.
C'est elle qui a bu.
C’est elle qui a accepté que
Jules la ramène chez elle.
Puis, elle était habillée comme ça.
Peut-être qu’elle l’a tenté.
Elle y réfléchit,
elle y réfléchit longtemps.
Au bout de quelques semaines,
elle se dit que ce n’est pas normal.
Elle décide d'appeler Paul.
Paul, le même qu'au début.
Elle sait qu’il a eu un problème
lors de la soirée aussi.
Du coup, elle lui raconte
et la réaction de Paul
va être la suivante :
« Attends, Lola, juste pour comprendre.
Tu es sûre de ce que tu lui as dit ?
Je pense que Jules,
il a mal interprété tes propos.
C’est un mec cool, sympa,
on le connaît, jamais il ne ferait ça. »
Comme un étudiant sur 5,
Paul ne sera pas capable
d'identifier un viol.
Quelques semaines après, Lola va décider
d’aller au commissariat porter plainte.
Elle fera partie du dixième de femmes
seulement qui va porter plainte.
Elle va être reçue par deux commissaires
qui vont l’interroger
longuement sur l’événement.
Combien de verres a-t-elle bu ?
Comment était-elle habillée ?
Est-ce qu’elle n’aurait pas
dragouiller Jules quand même ?
Dans la plupart des cas,
les commissaires vont
banaliser ses propos.
Ils vont la culpabiliser
de ne rien avoir fait
et ils vont être solidaires
envers son agresseur.
Après tout, Jules était un de ses amis,
quelqu’un qu’elle décrit
comme plutôt sympa.
Ce que les commissaires
ne savent peut-être pas,
c’est que dans 9 cas sur 10,
la victime connaissait son agresseur.
Après plusieurs heures au commissariat,
la plainte sera finalement enregistrée.
Elle sera traitée en moyenne
en quatre ans.
Il s’agit d’un viol,
un crime pénalement répréhensible
qui peut aller jusqu’à
quinze ans d’emprisonnement.
Cet événement va certainement entraîner
chez Lola un stress post-traumatique.
Cauchemars, anxiété,
perte de confiance en elle,
difficultés à avoir des relations
sexuelles et amoureuses.
Et ce n'est que la face
émergée de l'iceberg.
Peut-être que Lola va essayer
d’en parler à son école.
Faire en sorte de ne plus
jamais y croiser Jules
et d’étudier dans un environnement
beaucoup plus sécurisé pour elle.
Malheureusement, à l’heure actuelle,
les écoles sont très mal formées
pour gérer ce genre de situation.
C’est face à toutes ces épreuves
que j’ai décidé, il y a trois ans,
en 2019,
de créer l’Observatoire étudiant
des violences sexuelles et sexistes
dans l’enseignement supérieur.
Nous sommes une association nationale
composée de plus de 60 bénévoles
dans toute la France.
Nous luttons au quotidien contre
les violences sexuelles et sexistes
reçues par la communauté étudiante.
Notre objectif, c’est qu’un jour
on n’ait même plus besoin d’exister.
Même plus besoin d’exister parce
qu’on sera entendus, écoutés et compris.
Mais pour l’instant, on est là
et on va continuer à se battre
parce que le problème
existe et qu’il perdure.
Rien que le fait de prouver
que ce problème existait,
ça a été une épreuve en soi.
Lorsqu’on a créé l’association,
on était deux.
Deux face aux établissements
à leur demander de mettre en place
des vraies structures, une vraie
procédure, pour aider les victimes.
A l’époque, la plupart d’entre eux
niaient le problème.
Ils ne comprenaient pas ce
que voulait dire culture du viol.
Pour eux, ça ne concernait pas
leurs étudiants
et on n’était pas légitimes.
On était trop jeunes pour
s’intéresser à cette thématique.
Alors, on leur a trouvé des chiffres.
On a créé un énorme questionnaire.
On s’est backé d’un comité d’experts,
des pontes de la statistique
et de la sociologie,
nous ont aidés à gagner en crédibilité.
On a également regroupé
une équipe d’étudiants ultra motivés,
des étudiants géniaux qui avaient vraiment
envie de nous aider à bouger les lignes.
On a diffusé le questionnaire et très vite
on a reçu plus de 10 000 réponses.
Et les résultats étaient alarmants.
Les résultats ont notamment montré qu’une
étudiante sur 20 était victime de viol
pendant ses études,
qu’une étudiante sur 10 était
victime d’agression sexuelle.
Ce qu’on voit également, c’est que
les instances qui existent actuellement
ne permettent pas de libérer
totalement la parole des victimes.
Au vu des chiffres, seulement une femme
sur 10 va aller porter plainte pour viol.
Et cette plainte aboutira
à une condamnation
dans moins de 1% des cas.
Seulement une étudiante sur 10 va aller
déclarer les faits à son établissement.
Il est vraiment très rare que ça
la mène à un conseil de discipline.
Ce qu’on voit aussi,
c’est que la communauté étudiante
n’est pas assez formée
et sensibilisée à la thématique.
La notion même de consentement
n’est pas comprise.
J’en profite juste pour faire passer
un petit message aujourd’hui.
Un non, c’est un non.
Un « Mouais, je ne suis pas sûre »,
ça reste un non.
Une personne alcoolisée, c’est un non.
Une personne endormie, c’est un non.
Je sais qu’il est parfois difficile
de savoir quoi faire quand une amie,
un proche,
vient nous évoquer ce genre de violences.
Mais il y a quelques
réflexes, phrases-clés
qu’il faut bien garder en tête.
Ces phrases sont les suivantes :
« Je te crois. »
« Tu n’as pas à avoir honte. »
« Je suis là pour t’aider. »
Pour conclure,
si vous avez été touché
par la situation de Paul,
sachez que la situation de Lola
mérite tout autant d’attention.
Ça fait depuis 2019
qu’on se bat sur cette thématique
et que les choses ont très peu changé.
Vous avez peut-être l’impression
qu’on rabâche les choses
mais nous, ce que l’on ressent
c’est qu’on est entendus,
mais qu’on n’est pas écoutés.
Informez-vous.
Parlez-en autour de vous
et aidez-nous à faire bouger les choses
pour qu’un jour on n’ait même plus
besoin de tenir ce genre de discours.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)